[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
entre la poire et le fromage
les français ont une préférence avec
plus de 1000 variétés différentes et 30
kg consommés par an et par habitant
la france est le pays du fromage un
business qui ne connaît pas la crise
rodophe le meunier meilleur ouvrier de
france en 2007 et meilleur fromager au
monde la même année a su tirer son
épingle du jeu et c'est à rungis sur le
plus grand plateau de fromages au monde
qu'il vient faire son marché suppose
tout au tout tout ça en a d'autres à me
faire goûter ils sont tous pareils
spécialisée dans l'affinage l'entreprise
le nier a diversifié ses activités
elle est aussi une plateforme
d'expédition en france et à l'étranger
et c'est je crois que c'est à n'y as tu
as assez californie san diego
là bas ils aiment le beurre laval
acheter affiné expédiés mais attention
que des produits de qualité quitte à
mettre le prix
le prêt justifier aussi parce que dans
le haut de gamme on va travailler sur
des plus petites séries on va pas savoir
faire les mêmes économies d'échelle
qu'une industrie
quand on parle d'autres gammes on parle
de lait cru c'est plus fragile plus
compliquée à mettre en oeuvre il faut
plus d' analyse il faut des locaux
différents tout est plus cher tout se
valorisent différemment donc forcément à
la fin ça se ressent dans l'eure dans le
prix final bien sûr à rungis
l'entreprise le meunier s'est fait une
place aux frais une réputation qui
trouve son origine à plus de 200 km de
là
bienvenue à la croix en touraine à
proximité d'amboise se trouve la
fromagerie le meunier ici au milieu de
ses vingt salariés
le quadragénaire n'est plus seulement
rodophe le fromage et meilleur ouvrier
de france avec son col bleu blanc rouge
c'est aussi un chef d'entreprise à
l'agenda rempli et au timing serré
là on est en train de remettre en état
quelques quelques bâtiments basse
consacrant des un petit peu mine de rien
avant de poser ses produits sur les
tables françaises et étrangères
rodolphe a reçu le goût et la passion du
fromage en héritage dans cette
entreprise se perpétue une tradition
d'affinage et de fabrication depuis
trois générations président est là qui
sait ça c'est une grand mère ça c'est ma
maman ça voilà également même par sandra
carreau une histoire de famille qui
débute dans les années 40
la deuxième guerre mondiale
ma grand mère avait une partie de sa
famille qui était en zone libre
elles venaient les voir de temps en
temps et elle faisait de la contrebande
sur paris est-ce qu'ils habitent à paris
donc à remonter avec des fromages et des
poulets qu'elle et les bandes comme ça
sous le menton sur paris ben oui entre
42 43 44
je crois qu'une petite anecdote sur le
fromage de chèvre qui n'étaient pas
taxées par les nazis qu'occuper l'un la
france donc là pris moins de risques en
faisant que du fromage de chèvre un
petit pont contrebande
et puis elle a trouvé que c'était pas
mal ça s'était bien passé bien vendu
sayyaf et gagner sa vie et s'est dit
pourquoi est-ce que je continuerai pas
au début des années 50
les grands-parents le meunier s'installe
avec leurs chèvres dans une exploitation
en touraine et quelques années plus tard
étienne père de rodolphe créé les
premières chambres d'affinage en se
spécialisant dans le fromage de chèvre à
l'hérésie là je vais te montrer avant
une seconde je vais te montrer un petit
peu les fromages pasteur qu'on arrive à
sortir maintenant tu as vu les essais de
bûchettes au poivre ça c'est les
couronnes de touraine
super et puis maintenant on a toute la
partie bûchettes qui s'affine
parfaitement aujourd'hui à la retraite
etienne le meunier a vu avec fierté son
entreprise se développer sous
l'impulsion de son fils un succès
désormais international qu'il aurait lui
aussi voulu concrétiser en son temps ça
on a sorti sa yapo longtemps la sas et
les briauds truffe 3%
on est sur du bris traditionnel fermiers
coupée en deux
j'aurais aimé le faire mais bon j'étais
passé dont on dira c'était put pas tout
à fait encore la même époque
car c'était quand même plus difficile
c'était pas évident voilà mais il y en a
qui le faisait c'est sûr voilà j'avais
travaillé j'ai travaillé avec quelques
exportateurs mais uniquement généré en
région parisienne du côté de rungis et
auch occupaient les vendre à l'étranger
aujourd'hui leur relation est celle du
partage
impensable pour rodolphe de ne pas
évoquer par exemple
son projet d'extension je pense sur la
matière et la place de faire le beurre
l'autre moitié j'ai la place de faire la
découpe à point fixe la famille au
service de l'entreprise chez les le
meunier la tradition se perpétue
photographe de mode
diddy d'orzy la compagne de rodolphe
s'occupe du marketing
on se retrouve finalement la même chose
c'est de communiquer sur des bonnes
choses sont dures elles sont des voiles
en tout cas dans le domaine de l'image
donc que ce soit alimentaire mode pareil
faire rêver les gens
et même dans ce domaine rodolphe est
partout c'est dans son adn
il a toujours son mot à dire le moulé à
la louche c'est compliqué parce que
c'est vraiment on va dire entre
guillemets de l'argot français fromager
français moulé à la louche ou la louche
un américain ou un japonais pour eux ça
veut dire que c'est fait par une machine
industrielle depuis son titre de
meilleur ouvrier de france en 2007
bref le meunier a imposé ses initiales
dans le business du fromage
ici dans les halles de tours sa boutique
s'est agrandie en 20 ans et c'est sa
soeur caroline qui s'occupe de la vente
au détail
mais il n'est jamais loin alors cette
omniprésence marketing à gastel sa soeur
c'est quelque chose que on a longuement
discuté bredouille chez quelqu'un qui ya
arrive facilement à se mettre en avant
et alors que moi je suis un peu plus
réservés non ça ne va absolument bien
donc ça me correspond et de ce côté là
il n'ya pas d'ego ans et pour nous c'est
la même entreprise et tous les deux donc
donc voilà un mot notre père est assez
fier de ça et et on n'est que deux donc
il n'y a pas de souci chez les
commerçants voisins
le succès de la maison le menu est
appréciée même si la présence du
fromager se fait rare ils ont pas changé
du tout sont restés les mêmes qu'à rodez
je la vois plus souvent à ce que
rodolphe par contre il n'ya plus nous
voir beaucoup lui maintenant les
affaires les affaires les affaires sont
friandes
si l'entreprise le meunier est
spécialisée dans l'affinage rodolphe
s'autorise de temps à autres d'aller
faire un tour à la ferme là où tout
commence
qu'est ce qu'elle mange la ja du du plus
verts il ya différents types de
configurations mélanger oui nos cuisines
une mélangeuse et pour rassembler à la
fois les fourrages donc à la fois tout
ce qui est constant cette fin du maïs on
adore jma de la voile et c'est le lait
de ces chèvres qui sera transformé en
fromage puis achetée par la famille le
meunier à la laiterie la cloche d'or
depuis plusieurs décennies
tous les arômes du fromage tarte se
révéler et demain on va les mettre au
frigo et ensuite on pourra les camions
et c'est ici chez son fournisseur que
les premières idées apparaissent on
appellerait ça le mec you own fait le
tiens donc on pourrait imaginer un petit
tuto fromage et voilà je pars d'un
fromage tout frais salé comme ça blanc
de la fromagerie de la cloche et à la
fin le fromager se fait plaisir avec ces
différents ingrédients et peut lui-même
dans son magasin a ajouté cette épice du
moment sont curcuma qui peut y avoir
quelque chose comme ça de créer autour
de ce fromage près ça serait simple pour
les montrer comme ça tout bêtement ça
c'est intéressant retour à la fromagerie
à l'intérieur de ces caves d'affinage
plus de 400 variétés de fromages sommeil
pâte molle ou dure croûte fleurie au
naturel au lait cru ou pasteurisé cette
diversité est l'une des clés du succès
de l'entreprise
l'affinage reste le premier métier de
rodophe le meunier
durant ce laps de temps les fromages
sont retournés parfois fumée et même
travailler afin de leur donner
différentes saveurs j'essaye toujours de
trouver des choses à faire avec mes
fromages et des ingrédients locaux donc
avec les japonais je travaille avec des
fleurs de cerisier par exemple avec
dubaï et tous les émirats on va faire
des va travailler des mix avec du sirop
de date
en dix ans la société a changé de
dimension
son chiffre d'affaires a été multiplié
par cinq et celui du nombre de salariés
par quatre chaque semaine le patron les
réunit afin de discuter des projets en
cours et la réunion se termine par une
dégustation des nouveaux fromages sa de
la tenue c'est à la fois moelleux
parfumé pas trop fort non plus ça
correspond d'un très très large palette
ça c'est bien ça ça va plaire aussi bien
français comme les fromages maroilles ça
va lui plaire ça pas de problème qu'un
japonais que jamais manger un truc fort
de sa vie grâce à la multiplication des
réseaux de vente l'entreprise diversifie
ses sources de revenus un tiers est liée
à la vente au détail
un autre aux grandes surfaces et un
dernier tiers à l'export raconter ses
meules qui fait entre 35 et 40 kg à
savoir faire à peu près 30 38 kg voilà
c'est une leçon lamballe c'est pour un
client sa part à hong hong kong le japon
l'australie et les émirats ou encore les
états unis
l'entreprise est présente dans plus
d'une quinzaine de pays
miquel et oui je veux du camembert et
des produits qui peuvent voyager par
bateau camembert bris colomiers on va se
débrouiller pour faire quelque chose
et dans ce commerce mondial la france
attire les gens du métier au parc expo
de tours depuis 2013 se déroule le
mondial du fromage tous les deux ans les
professionnels du monde entier s'y
retrouve ici
dégustation et business font bon ménage
à l'origine de l'événement
rodolphe prépare l'édition 2021 une
édition qui sera digital et sans doute
fermé au public
c'est pas évident de faire venir les
japonais les américains on a un gars qui
vient du pérou on a un mexicain
heureusement qu'on apporte brésilien
parce que là c'était même pas la peine
même si c'est une année exceptionnelle
je trouve que ça encore plus de sens de
le faire et ce encore plus valorisant de
pouvoir promouvoir cette filière le ce
métier de fromager vis-à-vis de
vis-à-vis de tout le monde vis-à-vis de
l'international et de montrer qu'en
france même si on galère on est quand
même là pour faire les choses et on fait
tout ce qu'il faut pour qu'on puisse le
tenir tenir et faire mieux
doubler le chiffre d'affaires et le
nombre de salariés en moins de cinq ans
si le meunier s'est fait sa place sur
les plateaux de fromages
rodolphe lui a toujours un grand appétit
à rassasier
[Applaudissements]